allez il ya mille enfants alors
maintenant il ya presque toutes lettres
on peut alors là c'est vraiment le
châtelet de les trois mousquetaires mais
enfin il ya du monde autant en profiter
bah oui aulas cette situation est très
intéressante l'effet d'un yen dont élus
nous ont saisis dans le boudoir d'une
cocotte 1900 il ya du costume oui un
père tombe videront nez à nez avec son
fils c'est un pas qui va le faire c'est
lui tombe le mieux la chute à 8 ans lui
toujours maintien vous tombez bien vous
pour ça qu'on langage et le valet de
chambre tentera d'arranger les choses
voilà alors le père sera engagée car
elle qui avait deviné qui jouent ils les
valets de chambre sera jacques joyau de
la cocotte jean poiret ne pas le fils ou
la cocotte sophie des marais alors là
vous avez une phrase qu'elle vaut bien
la prendre
la phrase à dire dans les dernières
vingt secondes
oui ce sera quand vous dansiez dans ce
temps là pas besoin de [ __ ] wah-wah
quand vous dansiez dans ce qu'elle avait
dit la chanson garac la [ __ ] wah-wah
c'est la [ __ ] ce qu'ils vont en morale
assure les assauts agitator un peu aller
à ce qui se fait quand vous allez
essayer d'entendre
je m'arrangerai pour pas la dire sa
place au théâtre ça c'est les colliers
1900 tient en bacs et reviendra c'est
vraiment du valais fait 900 familles
est-ce que cela n'est pas très 19 avr
ça fait tout à fait si vous mettez une
décoration avant tout cas mes enfants a
permis à des pirates mais d'une
décoration louis la maison sont là c'est
pas mal à l'émission est terminée pour
avancer le fait qu'elle roule parce que
tu sais pas je suis jamais allé en fait
loire se jetteront dans les villages
algériens
je fais beaucoup mes enfants en tête
prennent à la nation
firma les madame qui doit revenir
maintenant à kiel tournoi vous savez à
natal - tu sais monsieur bouchard me
rappelle plus son nom générique sur
nouméa tentent d'allécher trop de mon
planning c'est ça oui madame je vais me
préparer mes photos en retard voilà je
fais moi cette idée mademoiselle
emilienne gros choc la cité si vous
voulez vous asseoir est bien le matin au
monsieur gros cheval m'a non non c'est
madame bronche pas très bien très bien
moi c'est monsieur paul roussenq
monsieur edgar barre au sol afin qu'elle
joue un bonjour madame au cheval vous
atteint avec la question doit écouter je
rêvais de ça depuis longtemps
oh écoutez depuis depuis pratiquement 40
ans maintenant cet été y est je n'ai pas
changé je n'ai jamais connu de femme
alors mon potager grande guerre je vous
ai tellement je voulais tellement
admirée quand vous étiez au théâtre je
voyais toujours papa papa mené tout le
temps ne pas pas de pattes alors venez
vous voir on vous a vu depuis des
générations madame alors mon rêve
c'était de vous battre et d'être près de
vous on veut dire est toujours or il
faut avoir vus émilienne gros cheval
dans attali quand même très très bonne
dans la création par la création bien
sûr des plus tard plus tard on me dit
c'est un emilienne gros cheval
or or le charme or il n'est pas né ici
or pas du tout madame venez venez serait
italie vous êtes presque aussi bien de
près ou de loin
vitoux
faut dire que j'étais très loin aux
fauteuils d'orchestre n'avions pas
beaucoup d'argent qu'est ce que je fais
émilienne madame à damien monsieur là
qui me vouvoie emilienne beau gros caca
mou je suis arrivé je ses jambes et tmh
eric portejoie au trésor j'ai vu il faut
de la porte
les voitures et les chevaux de mon fils
oh ça n'est rien tu joues est un
quartier sur quoi j'ai ce pardon j'ai lu
et je paye quoi faire quelques courses
jorge marquez je voudrais mais pas d'or
je ne tenais pas il écoute toujours ce
qu'on dit qu'on n'a pas d'étonner le
savez tous été très imprudent de venir
comme ça avec des trains corail de
décoration des cours d'eau du fleuve
oui mon avis attendez vous
qui est là maintenant c'est non c'est
rien c'est rien comment je sais rien
j'ai cru reconnaître cette fois debout
fiche et non pas du tout non c'est pas
la joie
moi qui révèle une vie de famille on
n'avait pas besoin de guitare wawa oui
elle sait plus du tout ça c'est quand
vous donne t on chez renault la pente
allons vous n'aviez plus besoin d'eux
bon